[Music]
few mythical beasts loom larger in the
human imagination than the dragon no
matter what form these scaly creatures
take or which folklore they come from
legends are almost always more
captivating when they include these
fantastical monsters but what might the
biology of a realistic order of dragons
look like classic books like dragonology
and fictional documentaries like
discovery channel's dragon special have
entertained this hypothetical idea in
the past and i won't deny that i read
and watched both of these series when i
was younger more times than i can count
but i've always been looking for a more
scientific take on these mythical
creatures enter drakenology a
meticulously detailed spin on the
concept that imagines dragons as a
peri-reptilian offshoot which emerged
millions of years ago and have survived
until the modern day the project was
created by the artist vikas rao and i
have links to his work in this video's
description his draconology series is
unbelievably comprehensive imagining the
genetics behavior taxonomy habitats and
even feeding habits of countless dragons
inspired by cultures the world over so
for this entry into the archive let's
make our own dragon documentary and
explore the awesome fictional science of
draconology
the world of draconology is set on an
alternate earth which saw the formation
of a few additional land masses and the
evolution of numerous creatures that
only exist in folklore on our own planet
chief among these are the draconamorpha
a branch of parareptilia which includes
sea serpents worms bird dragons like
griffins drakes wyverns and what the
author calls true dragons all of which
are extremely well realized and we'll be
covering in this video first up are the
sea serpents or the thalatophitia an
order of aquatic draconomorphs that are
a sister lineage to their land dwelling
cousins in the words of the author the
evolutionary origins of sea serpents are
as murky as the waters they inhabit but
it seems their ancestry dates back well
over 200 million years and thanks to
this alternate earth having slightly
different mass extinctions some still
roam its seas today in wetlands rivers
and estuaries throughout this world's
version of europe you may encounter the
knucker a long eel-like serpent with
sharp slicing teeth averaging around 16
feet or 5 meters in length the knuckers
are actually on the small side for a sea
serpent the author imagines their
flippers have a high degree of muscular
development allowing them to pull
themselves onto land similar to seals or
sea lions in mythology the term knucker
was a common name for a water dragon
with a version of the term appearing in
the 10th century epic poem beowulf
moving further out to sea to the waters
of the north atlantic and pacific the
northern sea orm glides through the
waters reaching almost 60 feet or 18
meters in length and weighing well over
a ton these creatures aren't built for
speed but foraging in the ocean depths
the long tendrils on its snout known as
barbells contain nerve endings that help
seaworms detect vibrations made by
swimming prey the animal's head is also
somewhat crocodilian and has a similarly
formidable bite force that aids in
crushing its unlucky meals
and in the depths of the ocean
leviathans lurk the two largest sea
serpents are the tiamat and the yorman
gander examples of abyssal gigantism
that get their names from ancient
mesopotamian and ancient norse mythology
and these legendary titles are well
deserved for the largest of the yorman
gander have reached lengths of 82 feet
or 25 meters and the largest tiamat not
far behind at 68 or 21 meters the author
imagines these species are able to
withstand the frigid depths they swim
through thanks to a network of heat
exchangers and a layer of thick blubber
which has allowed them to dive deep
enough to feed on organisms like giant
squids
in our next category we have the worms
long wingless quadrupedal draconomorphs
in many real world cultures dragon myths
don't feature winged fire-breathing
monsters but serpentine beings more
often associated with water or earth
which this group takes inspiration from
in the forests of east and southeast
asia the wide-ranging great wind worms
move through the canopy although they
lack wings this species is able to glide
from tree branch to tree branch by
flaring out their ribs and undulating
their bodies in a serpentine motion such
behavior is not dissimilar from the
rib-powered flight of real-life draco
lizards or the incredible gliding
techniques of paradise tree snakes both
of which are unique animals i've touched
on before in other entries
another amazing worm dwells in various
regions of north america the greater
banded utena at 14 feet or 4.5 meters
it's one of the mightiest species in its
family the otana pays respects to the
horn serpent motif that appears in the
oral history of numerous indigenous
cultures particularly the cherokee
people able to produce venom from a
specialized gland in its upper jaw the
otena is similar to the real world
horned viper one of the deadliest snakes
alive today
our third category are the amazing bird
dragons or orinthro draconia this
diverse order includes numerous mythical
creatures you might be familiar with in
west asia north africa and southern
europe for example you can find the
common cockatrice a unique opportunistic
forager that will eat just about
anything in conventional mythology
cockatrices hatched from a chicken egg
that was incubated by a toad here the
author imagines the myth comes from a
behavioral quirk of these reptiles to
lay their eggs and burrows dug out by
certain species of burrowing toads or
lizards
a strikingly tall bird dragon is the
giant keyring a heavy flightless
draconomorph so tall it could look a
giraffe in the eye these unique brightly
colored organisms are actually inspired
by mythical chimerical creatures in
various east asian cultures and have
gone by numerous names and the final
member of the bird dragons are the
griffins a family so diverse they
require their own separate section
called the grafana day these offshoots
have a superficial resemblance to birds
but their feathers are in fact epidermal
scales that have evolved into fur-like
cola fibers in the forests of atlantis a
fictional island landmass you need to
stay on the lookout for the atlantean
giant alk these species are the heaviest
of the griffin family to the point where
they've given up the ability to fly
giant out are also hypocarnivorous
meaning their diet is mostly composed of
plants rather than meat similar to many
species of bear soaring over the ocean
with a wing span similar to that of an
albatross the southern axex is one of
the smallest members of the griffin
family these creatures are opportunistic
scavengers primarily feeding on
carcasses and filling an ecological
niche almost like a sea going vulture in
this scene from the north specific a
northern axex a closer relative of their
southern cousins feeds on the washed up
body of a right whale which a great
white shark has also laid claim to and
the final bird dragon we'll be examining
is the lemurian giant axex another
species which lives on a fictional
island landmass the largest of the
griffin species though not quite as
heavy as the atlantean elk the giant
accent stands at over six and a half
feet or two meters tall this particular
griffin also feeds in shallow waters
with a feeding ecology similar to storks
or herons
in our next category we have the drakes
or therosuchia these heavyset flightless
draconomorphs are closely related to
what the artist terms true dragons which
we'll get to in a bit the author
imagines most drakes are semi-aquatic
growing to gargantuan sizes feeding on
vast schools of fish the largest of
these species the titan drake is a giant
among giants reaching lengths of up to
52 feet or 16 meters and weighing over
nine tons making them proportional in
size to a t-rex further out to sea the
swift makara have become even more
aquatic growing a long tail fluke to aid
in pursuing prey under the waves in
coordinated pods on occasion makara will
even attempt to catch their distant
cousins the sea serpents as you can see
here in this high-speed underwater chase
while the makara are fast most species
of sea serpents have better endurance
making this a tight race for survival
and now we've arrived at an amazing
category of flying draconiforms these
are the wyverns or vulanasoria an order
that is famous not for breathing fire
but for being highly venomous at first
glance these flying reptiles seem to
resemble our next category of true
dragons more than drakes or bird dragons
but the wyverns are actually most
closely related to certain worms on
various island chains the greater
frogmouth wyvern flits among the trees
feeding on small birds and reptiles
although capable of flight frogmouth
wyverns wings like the wings of moth
wyverns lack the air sacks that allow
true dragons to achieve liftoff despite
their far greater sizes as a result
frogmouth wyverns have stayed relatively
tiny not much larger than a crow in no
despite their name frogmouth wyverns
aren't imagined as being related to
actual frogs in the amazon rainforest
the much larger peacock wyverns also
achieve flight with wingspans reaching
over five feet or 1.5 meters one notable
trait of this species is their lethal
venom glands which produce a deadly
fast-acting neurotoxin to attract mates
peacock wyverns also possess bright
flashy colors much like real world
peacocks in the largest wyvern in this
fictional taxonomy is the new guinean
giant wyvern apex predators whose
wingspans get close to 10 feet or 3
meters in length like most wyverns these
creatures also possess potent venom
enabling them to hunt animals many times
their size impressive as these creatures
are however true dragons can grow far
larger
before we discuss the category of what
the artist calls true dragons however i
need to address a misconception i've
often seen online regarding the
difference between wyverns and dragons
that i may be a bit too passionate about
i've often seen people claim that any
dragon with two legs is automatically a
wyvern which okay obviously both dragons
and wyverns aren't real so who cares but
if we're going off mythology as a
president this division is far from
universal the number of limbs dragons in
medieval art have are all over the place
despite the misconception that dragons
always had four legs and two wings and
wyverns always had two legs and two
wings the wyverns usually had two legs
dragons and myth often had any number of
legs and yet could still be identified
as proper dragons if medieval myth is
your basis i think a better distinction
is that wyverns unlike dragons usually
couldn't breathe fire and were instead
venomous the notion of a hard division
between dragons and wyverns based on
legs alone is actually a very recent and
kind of subjective one so if you want
your dragon to have four legs awesome
but if you want them to have two that
doesn't automatically make them wyverns
again all of this is made up and i know
my feelings on this are unusually strong
okay back on track at last we've come to
the fire-breathing eu draconia often
called true dragons in this taxonomy who
you'll notice have two legs and yet
aren't wyverns among the ranks of these
dragons are the large fire-breathing
behemoths you'd expect but also smaller
more specialized species
the green dragonet for example is a
diminutive dragon that isolated on the
sullivan islands has adopted a curious
diet of raw fruits despite being smaller
than some wyverns the green dragonet
still counts as a true dragon thanks to
the brachial air sax on its wing and
because it retains the fire-breathing
abilities of its larger cousins
near the rivers and wetlands of the
fictional land mass of lemuria the
gargantuan lemurian dracolisk is on the
prowl despite having a wingspan of 44
feet or 3.5 meters the dracolisk spends
most of its time patrolling the water's
edge looking for food and has actually
taken up an ecological niche not unlike
a hippopotamus if hippos were carnivores
that hunted prey by setting them aflame
that is but how do the dragons of this
world produce their fire breath the
creator of this project imagines the
process begins internally starting by
combining endogenously produced
phyrophoric compounds in a specialized
reaction chamber located in the throat
the creatures then forcibly expel this
mixture outwards producing a powerful
jet of flame almost like a biological
flamethrower and the most impressive
fire breather of all is the eurasian
mountain devil a megaphone predator with
a wingspan of almost 50 feet or 15
meters these behemoths hunt by dive
bombing prey from above ending the
short-lived chase with a quick burst of
fire in build the eurasian mountain
devil almost reminds me of some modern
reconstructions of pterosaurs although
this dragon is larger than even the
mightiest of that extinct group in the
skies the mountain devils are unmatched
as you can see one here scaring off two
griffin with a jet of ominous flame a
truly intimidating creature
you can find more species and scientific
details on vicus rao's site using the
links below i'd like to give a special
shout out to ernesto marrero who i
believe was my 19th subscriber and the
first person ever to give me a
suggestion for a video back when i was
averaging less than 10 views in entry
his request was for a video on dragons
and i feel it's only right i finally
delivered so thank you ernesto it's
because of you and fans like you that i
make these videos in the first place and
as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support and like subscribe and hit the
notification icon to stay up to date on
all things curious see you in the next
video
[Music]
you